so barely onions Tim all Texas Tech and
the Player of the Year
Garrett calls texts emails rape his high
16 dat partly Jared clover off a broken
play and a freshman flinging the Red
Raiders to within three Jerris looking
timid and the ball was tipping caught it
nobody's better stopping for the dumb
holds a little bit stroke from deep
[Applause]
beautifully done
takes his tick punches pay seven
straight empty trips for Florida
over a nice play take it when push comes
myself they know how to dig in the
issues at this end of the floor you see
the drop bucket over take credible
finish the night and they trail by three
a pair for Tailored there's a slim cut
backdoor cut
and they finish it off with a block one
of the keys I think up there's a team
guys is three-point shooting 37% but
right now they're able to get to the
basket to call it with up and under nice
move good attack there by the Red
Raiders what you want to do is attack it
in the middle right there once you get
it in the middle covert it now turns
onto a one in one situation and now
because you have shooters spread out
you're able to dissect the defense and
get right down the middle
the next offensive possession go back to
Mitch and it just feels good soft bucket
oh that's the second time callers had
that little spin off the glass this time
a chance for a three-point play call for
excellent use of the screen tight curl
inside escape dribble and then able to
absorb the contact and finish Mooney
hooks it in the paint to own this now
Culver spins to the left-hand got
over go to work in space the nice little
bridge to cough spin move the soft touch
and finish one more time he in the lay
in with a left hand and a chance for a
three-point look the old EOS a five to
shoot
Felger back at his man down on a
fadeaway Top Shot guy I've been
recognized in its one-on-one at Bridge
this is a shot you want a fadeaway ever
shoot Lake Oliver
just got it away it's quarter
here's the slip cut trying to get in the
way of this one beautiful finish going
one-on-one with Culver and we got the
best of that eat me with the steel the
hesitation the span of the land right
now look at this quick move here by cold
couple yellow jerseys come over just a
little bow and here again you may not
I've never nothing he's got 19 points
remember this name because this young
man can get it done what he's just
putting on a show he's accomplishing
anything he wants taking the ball to
just good defense
moments ago October triple and check his
up by two they needed this bad he's
right here Culver has to get going
that's not an easy shot he had great
defense contested Korver's curve was
stepping up at the right time he was in
the left
votes great finish